pendant d
et je me suis posée
une
la nuit cette question elle est même pas
elle est même pas compliqué elle aime
pas compliqué mais elle m'a tellement
fait réfléchir que j'ai décidé de faire
un doctorat pour y répondre
j'ai monté une boîte pour y répondre
j'ai même écrit un bouquin dessus vous
dire à quel point ça m'a fait réfléchir
et je pense que si je vous dis je vous
la raconte cette question ça vous fait
rigoler qui est le plus intelligent
entre einstein et ribéry comme certains
diraient vaste programme
et c'est un sujet auquel je pense avoir
trouvé une réponse une réponse claire
que j'aimerais partager avec vous ce
soir
maintenant que je dors un peu mieux mais
juste avant j'aimerais revenir sur cette
notion d'intelligence et je pense que la
période qu'on vit actuellement pose le
bon contexte pour ça aujourd'hui on vit
dans un monde où il faut être au top
better faster stronger moi
personnellement j'ai le sentiment que si
je me relâche à l'instant je coupe un
peu trop de mes mails je coupe un peu
trop de mon rythme quotidien je
n'arriverai pas à me reconnecter
j'arrivais pas à prendre le dessus et je
me dis vraiment il faut rester au top et
sincèrement j'ai le sentiment que
c'était pas pareil avant que avant on
n'était pas dans ce rite on n'était pas
dans cette incertitude 7 soudaineté
cette brutalité
en fait cette incertitude 7 soudaineté
c'est la norme dans l'histoire de
l'homme est ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui
c'est un peu comme une parenthèse en
face qu'on a vécu jusqu'à présent ces
quelques dernières centaines ou milliers
d'années puisque avant la
sédentarisation avant les villes en gros
avant les dix mille dernières années le
quotidien était certain incertain et
dangereux chaque jour l'homme lutter
pour sa survie
imaginez dans la nature on n'a pas de
grosses griffes pour aller trancher des
animaux on n'a pas de carapace
impénétrable pour se protéger et face à
des prédateurs en fait dans la nature on
n'emmène pas lourd concrètement si on
regarde la chaîne alimentaire
une échelle qui va de un à cinq et demi
c'est un peu le jeu du qui mange qui 1
c'est le plancton tout le monde peut
manger le plancton le plancton peut pas
se défendre
cinq et demi c'est ce qu'on va appeler
les super prédateur l'ours polaire le
grand requin blanc
l'aigle royal aujourd'hui nous font pas
peur mais je vous garantis que vous mets
tout seul dans la nature et vous font
peur et nous parce que nous dans cette
échelle en fait on est à 2,2 2,2 sur
cinq et demi
pour vous donner une idée on est à peu
près au même niveau que les anchois et
les cochons oui tout à fait nos
prédateurs naturels sont les mêmes que
ceux des anchois et des cochons je vous
garantis que ça fait un paquet de monde
qui veut nous mettre venu et pourtant ce
soir on est là tranquillement assis on
se sent pas vraiment menacé
on est en sécurité on a du confort et à
quoi on le doit à sa banque en grande
partie on doit notre cerveau notre
cerveau qui est une arme adaptative
incroyable c'est notre cerveau qui nous
a permis d'utiliser notre environnement
pour notre sécurité pour notre confort
pour arriver là où on en est aujourd'hui
et plus particulièrement dans le cerveau
la couche superficielle qui fait à peu
près 2 mm d'épaisseur qu'on appelle le
néocortex c'est ce qui nous sépare de la
plupart des animaux et c'est ce qui nous
permet d'être conscient d'avoir toutes
les facultés qu'on a on va pas faire un
cours d'anatomie
mais il ya deux parties que j'aimerais
détaillé un petit peu sur ce néo cortex
et une partie la situe à l'arrière qui
s'appelle le cortex pariétal au niveau
de la calvitie chez les messieurs c'est
vrai facile à identifier et ce cortex
pariétal il est responsable de la
mémoire et des habitudes tout ce qu'on
apprend dans notre vie c'est stockées là
un peu comme le disque dur du cerveau au
xxème siècle en fait cette zone là
c'était la star c'est je vais pas le
faire ici parce que je suis pas sûr
d'avoir la réponse mais quand on fait
avec des gens qu'on 30 40 50 ans et
qu'on dit un gros 15 115
vous avez tout le monde qui répond à
gros marignan ah bon ça marche encore et
donc ça c'est pareil pour tous on devait
apprendre les départements on devait
savoir pourquoi parce que le xxème
siècle était un siècle où il fallait
exécuter reproduire
et finalement simplement renvoyé de la
connaissance et ça suffisait ça
suffisait pour être performant au 21ème
siècle
les règles sont différentes le monde
change en permanence et donc savoir des
choses ça nous sert pas à grand chose
déjà parce que google le sait mieux que
nous mais surtout parce qu'il faut
savoir s'adapter en fait ce qui compte
c'est de pouvoir utiliser son
environnement pour s'adapter comme dans
le passé et c'est ça l'intelligence
c'est la capacité à s'adapter et quelque
part j'ai l'impression que l'homme des
cavernes était beaucoup plus
intelligents que nous finalement parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous on stresse pas ce
qu'on va changer dix fois de job dans
notre vie et ça me ramène à ma question
qui est le plus intelligent entre
einstein et ribéry bon d'un côté on a un
scientifique de génie capable de
résoudre les équations les plus
complexes au monde et de comprendre le
monde comme personne d'un autre côté un
footballeur de génie capable de
prouesses techniques exceptionnelles et
j'appuie sur le mot exceptionnel on
prend l'exemple d'une reprise de volée
par franck ribéry il faut être capable
de voir le ballon arrivait une belle
parabole anticipé le point de chute du
ballon la vitesse résiduelles l'angle
puis positionner son corps dans l'espace
pour pouvoir frapper le ballon au bon
endroit avec le bon angle avec la bonne
force au bon moment c'est à dire à la
demie seconde précise puis ensuite
anticipé le mouvement des défenseurs la
vitesse du vent le mouvement du gardien
pour que le ballon finit dans la lucarne
tout ça en trois secondes pas
sincèrement einstein en trois secondes
il est pose pas tous les calculs pour
vous dire comment est ce qu'il faut
faire
donc c'est un fait
l'intelligence c'est de la puissance de
cerveau avant tout et les deux longs
einstein et ribéry ont une très grande
puissance de cerveau mais l'utilisent
pas de la même manière on peut comparer
ces deux grandes personnes à des
véhicules donc deux véhicules qui
auraient tous deux une très grosse
puissance de moteur les gros v12 d'un
côté
einstein ce sera un peu comme une
voiture de sport une très belle voiture
de sport très puissante
d'un autre côté ribéry ce serait comme
un bateau très puissant un hors bord
sauf que la société dans laquelle on vit
ah c'est plutôt une route elle favorise
les voitures de sport les personnes
comme einstein et pour les personnes
comme ribéry mais il faut arriver à
trouver son lac pour ribéry ça a été le
terrain de football
c'est ce qui lui permet de briller c'est
ce qui lui permet de révéler son
intelligence mais tout le monde trouve
pas son lac tout le monde trouve pas sa
forêt et donc finalement quand on pose
la question de qui est le plus
intelligent entre einstein et ribes et
ribéry on pose une mauvaise question on
pose d'une mauvaise question et c'est ce
que j'ai mis toutes ses années à
comprendre les intelligences sont
multiples louis elle passe par le fait
qu' on a une grosse puissance de cerveau
et après on a une sensibilité une
manière de l'utiliser
les hommes politiques les grands
cuisiniers les grands combattants les
vétérinaires chacun ils ont un énorme
talent à leur manière et il exprime dans
leur propre style et ça en fait dans mon
doctorat on a travaillé sur les critères
de la performance dont quelque chose de
beaucoup moins romantique que tout ce
que je viens de vous raconter très
irrité risée et en fait il ya quatre
grandes compétences qui détermine la
performance au 21ème siècle
dans un monde où tout change où il faut
s'adapter ces quatre compétences c'est
ce qu'on appelle les quatre c'est la
créativité pour pouvoir trouver des
idées originales
vu que les situations qui se présentent
on les connaît pas pauvre innover pour
inventer l'esprit critique qui vient de
critical thinking en anglais qui veut
dire penser la bonne chose au bon moment
pour pouvoir analyser et trier recouper
les informations faire les liens
résoudre les problèmes puis la
communication pour échanger des messages
entre nous parce que les problèmes il
faut les résoudre à plusieurs on est
plus gros on n'est pas tout seul
et donc ça ça demande déjà beaucoup
d'empathie cette notion de communication
l'empathie d'ailleurs on n'en a pas
parlé mais dans le néocortex c'est sur
le côté ce qu'on va appeler les lobes
temporaux avec les neurones miroirs qui
nous permettent de bien associer les les
émotions et les actions des personnes
personnels qui ont interagi encore un
avantage évolutif et la collaboration
qui a pour but de nous permettre
d'interagir pour pouvoir atteindre un
objectif commun créativité esprit
critique communication collaboration
ces 4 c elles sont au coeur de la
performance du 21e siècle
demain vous serez recruté par ces quatre
c'est demain au travail ce sont ces
quatre c'est qu'on cherchera à
développer chez vous et non plus le
cours d'anglais de base de demos non ce
qui se passera demain c'est qu'on
demandera de vous que vous savez capable
de vous adapter à travers ses 4 c mais
il ya une chose qu'on pourra pas choisir
pour vous c'est la manière dont vous
steve dont vous utiliserez ses 4 c est
ce que vous les utiliserez comme un
einstein comme ducasse comme ribéry
parce que vous avez chacun une
sensibilité de la société a tendance à
mettre les gens dans des moules
le système éducatif le système productif
le travail il exige de vous que vous
soyez des petits einstein et c'est ce
qu'on vous demande
personne n'a jamais transformé ribéry en
einstein
mais ribéry peut être ribéry et j'ai la
conviction que demain dans une société
tout le monde aurait développé les 4 c
mais chacun selon son propre style
on verra émerger une vraie société de
l'intelligence collective une vraie
société où chacun peut trouver sa place
chacun la chance de faire la différence
ça peut paraître utopique comme ça mais
j'y crois et je vais vous dire pourquoi
j'y crois pour deux raisons premièrement
parce que le cerveau et câblées comme ça
le cerveau est fait pour s'adapter
c'est intelligent ce qu'on peut appeler
logico mathématique kinesthésique
naturaliste peu importe on les a pas
inventé ce sont nos héritages
c'est intelligent ce sont des avantage
évolutif qui nous ont permis de survivre
et d'arriver là où on en est aujourd'hui
et la société moderne dans laquelle on
vit elle ne sait pas les exploiter
deuxièmement la nature la nature c'est
un très très bon benchmark
pourquoi parce que la nature et garde
que ce qui fonctionne donc si on observe
la nature on sait ce qui fonctionne
c'est le principe du biomimétisme mais
c'est vrai et dans la nature
l'intelligence collective existe à tous
les étages
qu'on regarde chez les fourmis chez les
abeilles chez les dauphins
même entre les espèces et dans les
écosystèmes matures ceux qui sont là
depuis longtemps
donc ce qui marche la compétition a
disparu la compétition n'existe même
plus remplacé par la symbiose par la
collaboration par par la coopétition
parfois mais globalement la compétition
a disparu et j'ai le sentiment que si
demain on accepte la diversité des gens
si on est capable de développer ses 4 c
sans forcément imposer un style pour les
développer on est capable de faire
émerger cette société de l'intelligence
collective
sentheim qui disait que si on juge un
poisson par sa capacité à grimper aux
arbres
le poisson finira par penser qu'il est
stupide alors moi je propose deux choses
je propose déjà qu'on arrête de juger
les poissons et deuxièmement qu'on les
laisse nager dans l'eau parce que
finalement ce sont nos héritages qui
vont déterminer notre avenir qui vont
choisir le modèle de société dans lequel
on va évoluer
merci